C'était une bonne idée.
Le harnais... une bonne idée mais qui n'a pas bien marché,
comme vous pouvez le voir...
Cette étape consistait à essayer différentes choses
(Rires)
En effet, cela n'a pas vraiment fonctionné...
Essayer et apprendre par l'échec la plupart du temps,
ce qui inclut des échecs sous la forme de chutes.
Vous remarquerez que nous avons 5 turbines
avec une sixième à l’entretien.
Un autre essai.
(Rires)
J'ai pincé une conduite de carburant. Encore une bonne leçon.
Nous avons appris à ne pas le refaire.
Nous étions dans une impasse.
(Rires)
Trois propulseurs sur chaque bras.
C'était ridicule. 70 kilos sur chaque bras.
Encore une chose à bannir.
(Rires)
Mais nous commencions à faire quelques progrès convaincants,
juste assez pour vous faire croire que peut-être, peut-être,
nous allions y arriver.
Regardez, ça a l'air alléchant.
Le concept d’un propulseur par jambe et deux par bras
offre une poussée suffisante en théorie.
Ensuite nous avons fait ce que je vais vous montrer.
Et j'adore toujours autant le regarder.
Voici nos 6 premières secondes de vol raisonnablement cohérent.
(Applaudissements)
C'est le moment où cette aventure est passée de
« Pas certain que ça va marcher » à « Oh mon dieu, ça marche ! »
A partir de là, nous l'avons amélioré,
tout en continuant à beaucoup tomber.
Tomber reste la meilleure manière d'apprendre.
Après un moment, nous avons amélioré la configuration de tout ça.
Vous voyez la stabilité et le contrôle.
Il n'y a pas de câbles ni quoique ce soit.
C’est la combinaison de nos efforts pour affiner la technique,
y compris le Tupperware dans le dos pour l'électronique,
tout en apprenant à gérer l'équilibre et le contrôle.
Je vais maintenant protéger vos oreilles en parlant sur le son,
car le bruit de l'engin peut être perturbant.
C'était il y a quelques semaines.
Vous pouvez voir que la stabilité et le contrôle sont bons.
J'aime penser que ceci valide mon hypothèse de départ :
le corps et l'esprit humain, s'ils sont correctement augmentés, comme ici,
peuvent accomplir de choses assez cool.
Regardez :
à ce stade, je ne me préoccupe plus du mouvement de mes bras.
Je regarde ma destination,
c'est un peu comme en vélo,
mes bras font ce qu'ils ont à faire.
C'est une expérience très étrange.
Où est-ce que je veux en venir ?
Je vais parler de l'atterrissage, il me semble que j'atterris dans ce test.
Je ne pense pas que vous irez faire vos courses
ou amenerez vos enfants à l'école avec cet engin.
Mais l'équipe développe une technologie incroyable
qui va rendre ceci simple comme un jeu d'enfant.
Nous travaillons pour permettre à un public plus large
de vivre cette expérience extraordinaire
au-delà de nos essais.
Nous recrutons les pilotes numéro deux et trois
s'il y a des volontaires.
Je nourris une vision,
sans doute audacieuse, mais croyez-moi,
que nous pourrons survoler des plages,
longer la côte de haut en bas, nous élever encore un peu
à l'aide du kit de sécurité que nous sommes en train de créer.
A l'horizon nous voyons un avion Hercule avec la rampe ouverte.
En passant à coté, on prend de la vitesse pour le rattraper,
par l'arrière, pas par l'avant, ce serait une erreur.
Enfin, vous poser à l'arrière.
Comme je le disais, ceci reste ambitieux.
Mais c'est aussi, si je prends un peu de recul,
c'est aussi un voyage très personnel pour moi.
Revenons sur cette photo touchante
ou photo dans une image.
Mon père s'est suicidé quand j'avais 15 ans,
en laissant énormément d'ambitions inachevées.
Il était un inventeur exceptionnel, un créateur marginal.
J'aime à penser, si cela était possible,
s'il nous observait, qu'il serait...
je pense qu'il sourirait certainement en voyant tout cela.
Tout ceci lui rend hommage.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Je suis encore plus stressé
de faire une demo après ça.
J'ai encore beaucoup de choses à faire aujourd'hui.
Le pire serait un mauvais départ.
Une erreur imprévue pendant le vol.
C'est pourquoi nous volons assez bas,
donc le pire serait de passer pour un idiot et tomber à l'arrière.
Vous pourrez tous en profiter si cela arrive.
(Musique)
(Bruit d'accélération de la turbine)
(Acclamations)